[Musik]
ich will zehn kilo abnehmen
nicht wirklich zehn kilo abnehmen
[Musik]
hey leute ich hier bin ich wieder eure
sport waren und wie ihr merkt es ist
schon das zweite video zu dem thema
abnehmen das liegt daran dass ich im
2022 main kanal so strukturieren möchte
dass es immer verschiedene themenblöcke
gibt gerade ist es fitness und
gesundheit und in ein paar wochen wird
es schon wieder was ganz anderes sein
ich hoffe dass euch diese abwechslung
gefällt und wenn ihr themen habt mit
denen ich mich mal länger beschäftigen
soll dann schreibt sie gerne in die
kommentare ich habe in den letzten
jahren ungefähr zehn kilo zugenommen ja
was denn so diese wohlfühl
beziehungschaos die man bekommt wenn man
über eine längere zeit seine
essgewohnheiten und seine sportliche
aktivität komplett ignoriert aber die
mich meinen körper trotzdem ja natürlich
für die organe gibt es eine eins plus
für den rest bin halt ich verantwortlich
weil ich auch dieses programm gefahren
bin erstens du hast dich nicht bewegen
immer schön den fahrstuhl nehmen und
nicht die treppe zweitens von zu hause
aus arbeiten und nur bis zu drei mal in
der woche das haus verlassen dritter vom
schreibtisch maximal zur couch und von
da aus zum bett bewegen bis zu 1000
schritte am tag sind okay 45 bei jeder
mahlzeit so viel essen das einem schon
der bau wehtut und ganz wichtig fünf
bitte gemüse nur in maßen genossen nhl
sex.com ja und so einfach ist es auch
schon an bevor sich jemand geschenkt
fühlt wir sind seit zwei jahren in einer
pandemie happy zwei jahre es geht vielen
leuten zurzeit so ich wollte also nun am
ersten ersten diesen teufelskreis
durchbrechen nach meiner henkersmahlzeit
an silvester mit einer ordentlichen
portion raclette hat es sich einfach
richtig angefühlt und ich wollte für
mich ein neues programm schreiben
erstens viel rausgehen spaziergänge
machen und sich dabei vielleicht neue
sachen anschauen zweitens das
fitnessstudio schon frühmorgens besuchen
damit man den schwierigen teil schon mal
hinter sich hat drittens jede mahlzeit
wirklich wahrnehmen sie zuzubereiten zu
genießen und neues auszuprobieren mein
körper und meine psyche leben dieses
programm aber eine frage geht mir nicht
aus dem kopf tue ich das alles wirklich
für mich oder weil ich schlank auf
social media sein möchte erste
quetschten
instagram weil ja schon einige zeit
unter uns youtube auf und schickt auch
ist so der neue player und so gern ich
wirklich realen content schaue menschen
folge die mich inspirieren und den
konsum so weit zurück schraube dass es
nach gesund für mich ist habe ich das
gefühl dass diese seiten nicht komplett
beeinflussen zumindest instagram und
tickt da brauche ich auch nicht lange zu
beschreiben was ich meine
dem fitness bezug finde ich dabei gar
nicht so schlecht viele influenza die
sicherheit beim trainieren zeigen was
auch wirklich der psyche gut tut also
deren psyche nicht meine ich hab
zumindest noch nie eine body
transformation gesehen wo jemand gesagt
hat dass er sie es vorher glücklich aber
und ohne irgendwelche studien zu
zitieren sport macht glücklich das ist
mittlerweile allgemeinwissen und über so
ein schönes motiv kann man zwar lachen
aber am ende des tages sind die gesünder
alten tüte chips am abend hektisch
doppeleffekt aber wie finde ich jetzt
heraus dass sport machen abnehmen gesund
essen wirklich mein eigener wille ist
oder möchte ich am ende nur mehr
aufmerksamkeit und eine positive
reaktion auf meinen eigenen körper und
wäre das nicht so schlimm ich meine die
sind ja soziale wesen und es wäre von
vorteil wenn mich die masse mag und
attraktiv findet es könnte ja noever
angreifen und dann heißt es natürlich
kinder und sexy frauen zuerst auf
rettungsbooten einer frau die ich sicher
aufs rettungsboot packen würde ist noch
unterhalb ist sie auf instagram tik tok
und youtube zu finden dort macht sie
sport und fitness content rezepte und
teilt ihren lifestyle mit ihren
zuschauern willkommen in unserer neuen
rubrik wieso weshalb warum wer nicht
fragt bleibt dumm wieso machst du
überhaupt sport ich mache sport war es
mir extrem spaß macht und natürlich als
ihm guttut wenn jeder kennt das gefühl
wenn man sport gemacht hat na und römer
oder sogar dann fühlt man sich viel viel
besser da nachts und ist energie die
lande ich bin viel positiver drauf viel
besser drauf ich strahle es aus stecker
andere leute meiner positiven energie an
die weiße sport gemacht habe und ich
habe mir auch immer vor augen das ist
eigentlich wirklich nur eine stunde am
tag ist wie ich mir selbst widme und
gönners ist zum einen die zahlen sagen
scheint immer einen ganzen tag arbeite
ich für mein strafrecht noch angestellt
und ich dass ich meinen hund ich
erledige papierkram unserer das konnten
wir kennen das wir machen die ganzen
sachen für andere menschen oder für jede
andere aber nicht für mich selber die
einer stunde sport tut mir hat auch
selig um kopf also so gut und das ist
halt das was sowieso spaß macht
weshalb ist das aussehen für viele leute
auf instagram so wichtig liegt das liegt
eher daran dass es in der natur menschen
oder in der gesellschaft verankert ist
ist auch so ein wenig mein auch bei der
partnerwahl man wählt den für sich
attraktiven menschen aus oder man möchte
sich immer von der besten schützen weit
dass ein familienfoto affenhaus macht
oder sonstwie es ist normal üblich dass
man sich eigentlich immer von der besten
seite zeigen möchte und so sauer auf
instagram es ist aber kein geheimnis
auf instagram ja dann fragt ja auch
immer mehr schein als sein dass da nur
so perfekt inszenierte bilder und so
vorhanden sind man zeigt sich nur noch
eine besten seite man selber muss sich
am morgen wie ich finde ja klar und
bewusst werden dass es wirklich viel
fake gibt auf social media ja ich hatte
mir das immer vor augen und ich selber
weiß was ich meine gummiteilen nicht
weißstorchs ohne filter und sonst war es
weil und photoshop kann keine plötzliche
kapazität für sowas wirklich ja so ist
es halt einfach irgendwie möchte jeder
hollywood mäßig ausgehen habe ganz schön
groß ist wie immer und so wie auch auf
kinder warum haben manche menschen
motivation für fitness und andere gar
nicht eilig und weiß jeder dass fitness
sport regelmäßig bewegung für den körper
extrem gut und gut für die gesundheit
ist aber umgehend von sich einige
trotzdem damit die menschen die
möglichkeit menschen die tiere ja viele
war nicht aus ihre kompressoren und
letztendlich ist der sport auch etwas
was anstrengendes du du schwitzt ja und
du musst die anschlusspunkte so weit ist
es halt nix gemütliches manche wollen
heißt so schnell das ergebnis haben da
so schlank werden gut aussieht wie neu
aber die lifte hin so fahren ehe er
nicht und ich habe meistens aber nicht
bewusst wie gut sich regelmäßigen wegen
für den körper ist liegt eine gesundheit
na ja einfach wirklich auf uns und durch
raus aus der kombination uns einfach die
vortag von ihm gegen euch viel spaß
machen mach erspart und dann wird es
auch besser durch was für mich das beste
nebenprodukt vor meinem sport ist
außerdem perfect body ist meine mental
health also wie ich mich fühle denn wie
ihr wisst leide ich schon lange an
panikattacken
angststörungen und depressionen würde
ich jetzt nicht so hart sagen aber ich
habe schon depressive phasen erlebt den
es mir wirklich nicht gut geht und in
den ersten wochen gehe ich jetzt diesen
sport mache habe ich schon eine extreme
verbesserung gespürt nicht nur von
meinem körper gefühl sondern auch hier
oben und ich rede da auch oft auf
instagram drüber aber ich sag das hier
noch mal gerne koffein ist glaube ich
für mich auch ein riesen triggern
gewesen den ich vor sechs monaten aus
meinem leben gestrichen hat und seitdem
geht es mir auch viel viel besser also
es lohnt sich auf jeden fall das mal
auszuprobieren koffein aus seinem leben
zu sprechen ist ich also ich kann sagen
ja zweimal ja dass ich jetzt in diesem
ganzen sport fitness wahn mitmache ist
natürlich einerseits kontraproduktiv
wenn ich an instagram denke und das ist
mich ja beeinflusst negativ und ich
jetzt selber sein content rein stelle
ich glaube der feine aber wichtige
unterschied ist dabei zu bleiben zum
beispiel habe ich jetzt auch filter für
mich gestrichen auch den paris filter
denen man auf instagram story einsetzen
kann ohne dass man sieht dass ein fehler
da ist da wird einfach so die haut globi
gemacht die poren werden verdeckt und ja
ich habe diesen filter jetzt aus meinem
leben gestrichen andere auch und möchte
wirklich ehrlich sein und ich glaube
beim sport ist es auch gut mal ein
schützendes gesicht zu sehen nicht nur
eine perfekte pamela reife ihre übung
der macht und war gar nicht schwitzt und
wahrscheinlich drei mal nach gepudert
wird damit wirklich alles makellos
aussieht oder sie jetzt zu beherrschen
sie ist wunderbar sie macht wirklich
einen guten job und ich glaube viele
leute bewegen sich durch sie vielmehr
aber in dessen urin es auch da
reinbringen zu zeigen vielleicht wie man
aufs travel ständig gesund essen zu
müssen die tradings zeigen einfach auch
so diese ups and downs mit einzubringen
und einem gefühl zu geben da ist gerade
ein echter mensch der gerade
echte dinge tut und die sind halt nicht
immer nur leicht und schön und instagram
möbel und in einem perfekten sportanzug
wo das top zur hose passt und die schuhe
sind auch noch makellos und eigentlich
ist alles perfekt also bin ich jetzt
über social media beeinflusst und möchte
deswegen abnehmen und gut aussehen ja
bestimmt also ein teil davon kann ich
nicht abstreiten aber das war in unserer
menschheitsgeschichte schon immer so es
gab eine zeit da waren auch mal kurvige
frauen angesagt ich vermisse die zeit
weiß dass während bisschen leichter aber
sport macht wirklich mittlerweile sehr
viel spaß und ich werde weiterhin nach
links und rechts gucken und mich
vergleichen das kann man nicht ganz
abschalten aber ich möchte meine eigene
geschichte schreiben und ich möchte mein
eigenes programm durchziehen und nett zu
mir selber bleiben ich glaube das
vergisst man manchmal am tag dass man
sich ja immer noch gerne haben sollte
habe ich schon mal gesagt ich sage es
aber gerne noch mal 70 selbst denn ihr
geht nur mit euch selbst ins bett und
vielleicht mit einem schnarchenden
partner aber in seinem kopf sei dir
selbst und wenn ich ein paar von euch
mit meinen videos motivieren kann dann
ist das super und wenn es nicht so ist
das leben geht weiter wir sehen uns dann
das nächste mal wieder ich hoffe euch
das video gefallen vielleicht könnt ihr
ein bisschen was mitnehmen wir sehen uns
immer wieder